hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm in lost really [ __ ] I'm
here in Los Angeles California maker
studios to participate in the rayman
legends come foot tournament where i'll
be facing off against 16 other youtube's
from polaris well yeah and we're gonna
be facing in the first round Ivy League
Punk and caters gamers versus me and my
teammate that oh boy do that to you of
the channel build gum bull Brenner of
burger pal will be my teammate in the
tournament so be sure to see my
first-round pick and really really
really why God so see our POV on the
channel next week and then be sure to
click in the link in the description
below to see everyone else's first-round
picks and see if I made it to the finals
maybe I don't know so thank you all so
much for watching be sure to share the
videos around and do whatever you can to
promote this in any way it's gonna be a
huge deal so don't miss out so thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you mother